Frank Fiedler joins me now.
He knew several of the victims.
His company,
Defense Systems,
had conducted
active shooter drills at Covenant School,
and he did a walkthrough of the school
today with officials to help
try and understand what happened.
And I should note, as,
of course,
you also spent 18 years
working for the Nashville
Police Department,
and their actions, of course, saved
so many lives in this shooting this week.
So I do want to ask you about your walk
through in just a moment.
But first,
these live pictures of what you're
you know,
what's happening right now in Nashville
and talking about the victims.
I know you knew a few of them
and including
nine year old William Kinney.
His father, West, is a friend of yours.
And I know he was out of town
during the shooting and had texted you.
What more are you able to
tell us about that?
Nothing more than that.
He was concerned about,
obviously, the location of his son
and he knew
we were conducting
training at the school.
He knew I was a former officer
and thought
I might have some insight into that.
And I did not, unfortunately for him.
And at the time,
we were actually out of town,
we were in Memphis, Tennessee,
working with another school
so I couldn't
get any more information from him.
And tragically,
his son,
Will, turned out
to be one of the victims.
You also knew the head of school,
Catherine Kuntz, and Mike Hill,
the custodian,
because obviously you
you know,
you had had done training at the school.
What can you tell us about them?
Mike, I met a few times.
I didn't know him well.
Catherine had a very
good relationship with
I actually just saw
a couple of months ago,
I ran into her at the bank
she was the type of person that knew
this was a heavy topic and knew
she had to be very careful
about bringing this
in front of her educators.
But she was also adamant about doing that
because she understood
the severity of the topic
and the severity of
the teachers
needing to have the knowledge
of what to do in that situation.
So she actually did her due diligence
so much
that she came and sat in
on our training at another school
first to make sure
it was what she wanted for her staff.
And then we worked very closely together
to customize
that training program for this location
and advise them on some physical security
and teach them what to do in the moment.
And so she was steadfast
in her commitment
to doing this
and in her commitment to these kids
and more importantly, her staff
and their ability
to perform under stress.
And she did
and I did mention that you did that
walk through of the school
today with officials
and obviously because of her. Right.
You'd conductive actor
active shooter drills there
before because she felt
this was so important.
We've all now seen the
video of the shooter
walking through the halls
on the surveillance video
as you were going through today
with officials trying to understand
what happened.
What what did you see?
What stood out to you
Well, a lot of it I can't talk about
because it's still an open
homicide investigation.
I will say this.
I want to make this clear to this story.
You know,
the whole story here
is about these teachers.
People are talking about the training
we did with them.
And yes, training is important.
But I wasn't here on Monday.
They were here right.
Their ability to execute
literally flawlessly
under that amount of stress
while somebody is trying to murder them
and their children.
That is what made the difference here.
And that is that, you know,
these teachers are the reason those kids
went home to their families.
Again, the
training is important,
but we weren't the ones executing it
in the moment. They were.
I will also tell you from the walk
through that
the only victims
the shooter
was able to get to were victims
that were stuck in some sort of open area
or hallway.
Everyone else was.
Several were able to evacuate safely.
The ones that couldn't do that
safely did exactly what they were taught
and trained to do,
and that was lock down
and fortify their position.
They did that.
The shooter
fired multiple rounds
into several classrooms
and was not able to hit
any of the victims
in those classrooms
because the teachers
knew exactly what to do,
how to fortify their doors
and where
to place their children in those rooms.
So I just want to be clear that
that this story needs to be about them.
Well, it's
pretty incredible that they did that.
I mean, it's not it's
not their job, right?
They're not there to do that.
And that they did that and did it
right and saved all those lives.
I mean, the horror
and the tragedy of the people
who are in open spaces
and I know your friend Catherine,
you know,
it appears
may have run towards the shooter
to try to stop
to try to stop it,
but that so many lives
were saved despite, as you say,
live rounds being fired into classrooms
that no one in those classrooms died.
You know, when we saw the shooter
initially go into the school by,
you know,
shooting at those glass doors
and going in right sort of
kamikaze style,
when when you heard about this
and you you knew Katherine,
you had been in that school.
You had trained
what actually went through your mind
So when we were in
Memphis assessing
this of this other school,
because we still have such a
deep connection
to the police department,
we were getting
pretty UP-TO-DATE information.
And,
you know, at first it was very surreal.
You know,
I knew because of what I do for a living
and because of our company growth,
I kind of knew eventually
that it was going to happen
at one of the facilities
or one of the schools
or whatever that we had trained.
But it's still never.
It's still very surreal right now
and today
and very tough, I'll say.
You know,
because we
we walked that crime scene,
even though it was very tough.
It is important
for us to learn from these events
and get better moving forward.
But at the same time,
I felt confident that the people here,
because of Catherine's commitment,
to this program,
knew what to do
and would execute flawlessly.
I'm just proud they did.
But I really
I really felt like they would
because every one of these people
took this training seriously.
And we had
extreme buy in from every faculty
and staff member.
Brink, thank you very much.
I appreciate your time.
Thank you for having me.
All right. Thank you.
And I hope so many here
his words that with all that training
and he actually knew that at some point
it would happen in a school
that he had trained
just to even think about that,
that that's the reality
that we're living in this country
as a very hard, hard to process.